[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about whatever way what
and today we have Kelsey I see welcome
back good luck you're welcome in the air
last time oh you're so good lucking what
you been up to
oh you know same [ __ ] different day
that's why you get invited back you know
because you come in here and you machine
gun us down with compliments
you guys look and we come back and were
like we love this person I don't know
why but something about her she needs to
come back yeah no one ever told me I was
going yo yes she did she said I believe
her hitting on you both as a couple
remember thank you not sorry
not just that again a [ __ ] heart beat
you also always have this great energy
where so many la people you you're like
how what's going on with you and they
list the five things that they can brag
about to you and you're like whatever
know each other
oh you're right you're why well we got
her cousin Nikki oh so you don't know
him no I know him
yeah we get along yeah yeah we have a
holiday relationship yeah baby you don't
have anything to brag about I took a
great ship
awesome those are good what are you so
Hollywood what determines a great [ __ ] I
think anything that doesn't require you
don't break a sweat oh [ __ ] I don't it's
not the sound oh I like it when like you
force it and you can hear it hit the
bottom of the toilet boom was like
[ __ ] Chernobyl bomb you should punch
this I try to change the shape of the
poop ones it's the bottom of the toilet
dr. Green Lantern of [ __ ] who's
Greenland he shapes different objects I
guess I'll get nervier nice comment nerd
humor is very huge right now actually
you're that you're actually the loser in
the room that would just be in the room
check the box office okay nerds took
over you guys lost never heard of attack
of the nurses attack with me when you're
[ __ ] white fingers sticking up in the
air oh you got white fingers too pal I
do on the front factor we all got white
fingers in the front I got red fingers
on the palm side read palms
strangely red why are they so red what
you do get a bruise here I don't know oh
it start it's a mess
I'm a dirty girls like damn you a
bruiser pong I did Saturday but ladies
sometimes that happens right really I'll
never do that really long as I can goes
maybe three days maybe but I think cuz I
have so much hair and it's thick you're
not greasy I got I don't know I use a
lot of dry shampoo cuz my swim I was my
girlfriend Jess she doesn't shower
sometimes her hair she's sitting over
there she better defend yourself
amazing okay that's what he always says
my private rooms I know so much about
jazz mojo wait how long can guys go
without ancient guys four hours really
stick my hair don't smell that
[Laughter]
so so we don't the stereotype is we
don't have some thingy sweaty skin but
hair and [ __ ] breath is dangerous
yeah you also have no like body hair
okay I am or are me other both yeah for
sure pretty far II I'm very bitter
you're normal
thanks kinda I don't know anyone that
doesn't have a fun smelly ass this is
we're talking about whatever you want
goes horribly wrong this is the
consensus is that you can go how many's
without washing your hair is a zero
there's that's a [ __ ] stereotype
because I have the most oily hair of all
do you know what I just saw a recently
on on Twitter that was so disgusting it
was like this white people thing that on
Facebook how they were saying yeah oh I
know what you're talking about
they say that that white people consider
going to the swimming pool and going you
have an ocean as a shower
yep that's an absolute shower know what
I think it's fine I think it's what
what's the difference I think so in
Hawaii
oh yeah just focus that is the beach
seven days in Hawaii yeah I was in the
pool three times a day tightening all
the chemicals out did you just Corinne
girl just just killed herself on camera
and everybody missed it okay guys well
you would have given her at that time
no but yeah they were right they were
using that argument that the chlorine
and the water just infects all the germs
I'm like it's just a person in this show
yeah they're just idiots everywhere
that's yup
it's just water where do we define as a
shower a shower is soap and water
I don't shower ever cuz I barely use
soap why cuz I don't have any you are
[ __ ] alluring dude I'll use some some
I'll use some shampoo what do you use on
your pajamas I shampoo you shampoo
tweeze it need to uh that much hair down
there and
I keep it high your what do you shampoo
it's like the Illuminati they let you go
I do the same okay let me guess this is
how you shower right you first get the
shampoo you get in your hand you're like
I got extra soap let me guess
but then three minutes ago he's like I
smell so bad it's like oh yeah yeah dude
put it together bro you also see the
thing that was big on Ellen we're we're
saying some people don't wash their legs
in the shower that's weird really
sometimes I guess drop your legs I'll do
that but I think because girls we shave
so it see they're like I'm either
shaving aka getting shampoo all over my
legs or I'm not do you exfoliate
sometimes it's like that be a special
occasion you know they do the only will
you shave you're scrubbing off the dirt
anyway with the razor no I would be
nervous that Joe has your back confident
yeah I would too
okay let me tell you something okay
stick to your guns oh no no I am going I
had one of those people that skip the
legs sometimes because I'm washing and I
get tired during the calf part and I go
well you know what my feets gonna get
dirty again anyway Wow you probably pee
in the shower too
yep you don't do that I do I don't do it
since I became a homeowner what that's
right I'm not gonna do that value my own
property no [ __ ] way
I'm all about the value here's the thing
I used to pee poop everything in the
show till I bought a home you take a
[ __ ] in the shower and then you stomp it
down dirty [ __ ] filthy Rena literally
pictured toes just smashing into like a
[ __ ] ground beef grinder
what's your question on my poop on my
poop story they have two options like
the first one is you do what you do the
[ __ ] [ __ ] grinder the other one is
you pick it up and then throw on the
toilet the third option is once you sit
on the drain can I just sat on it
can I just say I wish I was talking to
Barbara Walters right now puppets well
Barbara why don't you just unscrew the
drain so the drain thing and just have
it open so I know a guy I dated every
time he took his [ __ ] he had to shower
right after he got clean he didn't even
wipe you just get straight in the shower
yeah the clean guys cleaned up but it's
extra shower was disgusting it's pretty
extra damn wipes can use the Saint I've
seen I have the pH balance [ __ ] clean
there's a brand deal no but could you
said shampoo ever I thought girls use
the UH
I thought they're supposed to use that
pH balance or depakote scrub dude don't
use that [ __ ] on your vagina vagina soap
and regulates got things ever happen to
my [ __ ] day nothing's ever happened
your vagina
you've never had a yeast infection no
you've never you see I know how do you
for every one hand yes but I've never
had a yeast infection but what's the
only difference is one is you just got a
little dirt in your cooch and the other
one is is overgrowth of bacteria yeah
the ones internal one is that I know
this that or the other I'm just saying
what I've had it hadn't had but I do use
that [ __ ] the [ __ ] veg so oh and
that's how you exact that so sweet
harmony
no way I think it's easy easy Eve have
you ever seen the pH pH strips you can
swab your puss with a cello I just
discovered these and I keep them like in
every [ __ ] pH like a fish tank why do
you need to know your pieces are a [ __ ]
okay I believe my pH is I even all the
time will find out that it's uneven how
do you control it you put like chemicals
in there oh my gosh it's a little time
it's like it's like it's like a
chemistry test you literally stick it up
your couch in the second hole montt the
first and then you pull it out and you
compare your second hole wait a minute
liquored [ __ ] no no I know this is
the second hole for me so and then you
comparable vova oh then you compare it
to the colors on the box and if it's
light yellow that's good but if it's
like dark down eh is off that's how you
test your pool too
it's exactly like that my fish if it's
off you [ __ ] shove a [ __ ] boric
acid pill up there you cranberry juice
it or you you can tell if you're getting
a UTI or a yeast infection so sometimes
I'm like damn I'm acid yeah I'm like I
got acid [ __ ] don't sing in a city all
about basic [ __ ] need a [ __ ] get up
boy that's it yeah black hole sizzling
I've experienced that before yeah for
sure
like well it's not like it's not like
Duracell batteries strange very strange
wait did you like how what'd you do put
taco in there no I didn't do anything
like that you look at you're like
[ __ ] like electrical charge to it
kind of thing I think [ __ ] might
taste like pennies when you know but
when it's nice I like it period I like
it you like penny [ __ ] no no I like
regular tastes okay well I was just at a
video where we talked about a bunch of
box on the period and I was like not for
me but I support it apparently a lot of
people [ __ ] lunchbox I'm on
period see I think that's a humiliation
thing some people like it's like old
robitussin dollars left outside
robitussin that shit's expensive
dude this guy's leaders were over tested
at the Sun bro man that dangerous
looking at he's like that's interesting
just for life you know y'all have a real
night shift like in high school
no druggies okay robitussin has this
[ __ ] keV it's it's it's I forgot the
name of it but it's similar to the
effects of e wah wah bland wah wah like
if you but you got to drink a lot of it
you got to drink like the whole bottle I
don't know if it's the same chemical
compound but they stopped selling this
in robitussin I think they changed
ingredient dude I remember high school
is getting robitussin getting [ __ ] up
remember that's it
I never heard of that I just felt it was
too much liquid for the amount of drink
off [ __ ] on you had to drink the whole
bottle yeah stand for what does it look
okay I used to get bored as [ __ ] up my
old office job and I would pop a
benadryl or what we called it pop and
Benny's and that was pretty sick because
you feel like you're underwater and then
when the phone rings like you're just
like because you're just in another
planet yo I knew a benadryl not a large
man oh I could only take one Justin what
is benadryl supposed to do you have no
[ __ ] idea I'm not sure the [ __ ] yeah
now drowsy - makes you sleepy I don't
understand know exactly what I took when
we went swimming with the sharks and I
was knocked out the rest of the day and
cause a dangerous situation
[ __ ] on a David girl yo did you make it
in the water no so I took it cuz I
didn't want to get both 6 and 6 and then
I made it throughout the whole activity
but then afterward you could have been a
floater fish with allergy medicine not
her to drown me [ __ ] pepto-bismol
before I go on his [ __ ] boat trip
putting on a [ __ ] snorkel anyone
non-drowsy and i did it guys I have
heart palpitations so it took cough
syrup you know I mix it up doesn't just
have like a fuckload of caffeine in it
oh yeah kind of caffeine yeah what does
that mean you don't get a crash don't
ask too many questions right enjoy
I just don't prefer the taste and just
how I feel afterward it tastes like
something I've had before matcha has so
you it you're taking the whole leaf imma
get a little nerdy but here's the thing
it releases their happiness below so it
doesn't hit you like hard and fast like
coffee doc are you supposed to stop
drinking in after like 5:00 p.m.
probably you're probably gonna be up oh
well it's got this jittery crazy
caffeine it's more like a awake caffeine
oh I like that
it depends on how caffeine tolerate your
choice um well you should do a lot of
coke but then I stopped and then I don't
drink coffee so what is that really have
caffeine like ever I know why my usual I
feel like I know like you would have
high times
yeah others what's the coolest surface
you snorted cocaine on who Oh someone's
[ __ ] or dick really for sure
Florida you keep it on the dick don't ya
I feel like you would fall I never did
coke I smoked crack never you went
straight from like weed to crack I coke
wasn't popular when I was young what we
bore the sixties Jesus no that's it it's
expensive yeah that's like for rich kids
girl yeah
I've never even actually sat there and
looked at coke as a kid I've always seen
meth and crack what is the what does it
look like crack yeah shards of glass
right meth looks like msg have you seen
like the crystals yeah it looks like
crystalline sugar rock can you bring
about is that rock can I bring him in
yeah they did their own like version
full of blue it she was like yellowish
well it was initially before he did the
blue thing in my face it's not crack
crack looks like uh soft white rocks but
it looks like kind of Beijing it wasn't
hard to stop oh I never got addicted
that's it's it's crazy like the things
that are highly addictive like I would
smoke it with my friends and not ever
want to smoke again yeah I heard
something interesting yesterday my
friend who is gay and he's like super
dooper in the gay community because he's
gay was talking about how there's like a
code word that you put in your Grindr
profile if you do meth which is you
capitalized the letter T in your profile
so if you're like likes to party and
then like a capital T that means you do
mess so then how do you even pass this
information around because I saw an e
Mon Twitter about it and I was like hey
gay person that I know what does this
mean and he was like oh because there's
a lot of meth in the gay community and I
was like I didn't think I knew my party
all night I have met sex yeah and so
what's miss sex
I think sex on meth hey go for that yeah
my painter back last oh do every quickly
mm-hmm yeah I don't know I I think um
when I did those things like my friends
got super hooked and I I smoked my first
time really smoking crack was a forty
hour binge we just kept going and going
and then we ran out and then the dealer
was asleep so that we just went to
downtown LA in the middle next to
MacArthur Park and they were just
looking around saying cocka cocka and I
was like this kind of race is just
saying that out loud to Mexicans and
then a guy comes up to our car he was
like yeah and he just [ __ ] grabbed
some money through some stuff in the car
very cool oh he was like poka poka
Daniel willy-nilly on the street I mean
I was like 17 and then I was in the car
for guys that were already experienced
like crack crack star you know they do
that at making hours huh if they do in a
Vegas now you know the on the sidewalks
or the passing out the naked pictures of
chicks yeah there's people just yelling
random [ __ ] to like drugs
oh they'll be like yeah like Oh girls
shows your Kirk and I'm like yep is it
[ __ ] straight all of my dad would you
guys ever do drugs on your parents yes I
need to see what might who my dad really
is because I think he built up this fake
person over the last 60 70 years I just
wanna know who really is on me so I
could see with him with your parents oh
yeah massaging each other all night
talking about your life I think I need
to have an intervention of my family cuz
they're so [ __ ] boring I really need
I really want to like just sit him down
and be like you guys are so [ __ ]
boring what we're gonna do about this
show do something
yeah I mean dude they just [ __ ] sit
there and like everyone just sort sort
of is breathing in the room and like
looking down and like so what's up and
you have the same conversation 14 times
in a row and where are you from San
Diego does even talking about them are
you sure you should bring over chutes
and ladders or something cards against
humanity' parents love that because they
think it's just so raunchy that's true
they think it's nuts they think it's
like they're doing e yeah
no god no no no my my family's insane
but we're from Florida
she told us remember yeah what's normal
Oh dad's a preacher right oh you know my
grandpa is a scam artist peachy's
knocked it was so high he's in the
hospital I'm laughing because I'm
uncomfortable I get it I'll do that
now you're there in a room full of
suppressors
okay yes that's for sure yeah